bonjour gérard olive et merci d'être
avec nous en direct sur arte france
alors quels sont les points forts et les
points faibles de chacun des candidats
pour cet exercice est ce qu'on peut
considérer qu'il ya une pression
supplémentaire sur les épaules de donald
trump qu'ils redoutent peut-être de
devenir le premier président ne pas être
réélu depuis plus d'un quart de siècle
alors tout d'abord c'est gérald un
olivier général mais en ce qui concerne
le débat de ce soir
la pression est sur les deux parce que
joe biden on l'a vu il mène une campagne
très discrète comme vous l'avez dit il a
des problèmes avec ses maladresses et on
a vu que récemment il avait aussi des
difficultés avec des trous de mémoire et
des difficultés d'élocution
donc la première chose que lui va devoir
démontrer c'est qu'il serait capable
d'être président qui là encore le samyn
aquila l'énergie qu'il à l'intellect
pour être président ce qui n'est pas le
diable plus simple au monde donc une
certaine pression sur lui sur trucks la
pression ça va être
et bien de comme d'habitude montrer
qu'il est le plus fort et c'est vrai que
c'est un bagarreur
donc c'est un contexte que lui apprécie
beaucoup et c'est vrai qu'il va
s'attendre à être attaqué et qu'il va
chercher à se défendre
la subtilité du débat peut être du côté
de brydon ça va être justement de ne pas
attaquer directement trump pour éviter
ce type de confrontation mais au
contraire de gentiment détruire tout ce
qui peut être son bilan et notamment de
se focaliser sur le corona virus qui est
l'échec principal du point de vue
démocrate de la gestion de donald trump
et se concentrait aussi peut-être pas
sur la violence et les difficultés
raciale et à quel point tu rome peut
être un président qui divise l'amérique
même si objectivement l'amérique et déjà
divisé il ya tout ce que vous venez de
citer à au menu des discussions en ce
soir à la violence raciale la crise
sanitaire
la succession à ruth bader ginsburg
également à la cour suprême mais est le
changement climatique est le grand
absent des sujets abordés c'est pourtant
apprend important pour départager les
deux candidats
alors il ya également la politique
étrangère qui est totalement dehors de
ce débat il est possible qu'ils en
parlent dans les deux débats qui auront
lieu un petit peu plus tard au mois
d'octobre le changement climatique tout
le monde sait ce que tu en penses
8 n'y croit pas il est sorti de l'accord
de paris il est très probable que si jo
bryden
élu président les états unis
réintégreront d'une manière ou d'une
autre cet accord mais s'il y avait débat
sur le réchauffement climatique trump
irait tout simplement parler à nouveau
de ce que tu appelles en anglais rocks
c'est à dire une fausse histoire une fac
news son point de vue sur le sujet est
extrêmement connue à l'avance est ce que
c'est c'est traditionnel duel télévisé
aux etats-unis ont-ils un véritable
impact sur le positionnement l'électorat
alors il faut non parce qu'en fait ce
qu'il faut convaincre ici ce sont les
indécis et ce qui est très important
techniquement l'élection a déjà commencé
il ya déjà des gens qui ont commencé à
voter qui envoie alors leur bulletin de
vote par courrier donc un certain nombre
de gens il est trop tard pour les
convaincre puisqu'ils ont déjà décidé
par contre on sait que le scrutin risque
d'être très serré très indécis et que ça
va se jouer sur les 10 % d'américains
qui aujourd'hui encore ne savent pas
pour qui ils vont voter qui se situent
plus ou moins au centre de l'échiquier
et c'est à eux que chacun des deux
candidats va chercher à convaincre donc
le premier débat a toujours beaucoup
plus d'importance que les deux autres
parce que c'est celui qui établit le
rapport de force
moi je m'attends à ce qu'il y ait une
audience extrêmement importante
enfin cette nuit pour nous et et ce soir
pour les américains surtout encore une
fois que on se pose des questions sur
les capacités de joe biden alors lui a
réussi à faire baisser un petit peu les
attentes
c'est à dire que si il s'en sort à peu
près bien celui qui sera déclaré
vainqueur du débat
trump à une barre un petit peu plus
élevé mais je m'attends à quelque chose
de très serré et de relativement tendue
au moins au début
alors dernière question rapidement
donald trump a demandé un test
antidopage pour son rival qui l'homme
jul endormi puisqu'il considère que ses
performances lors des débats ont été
inégales comme jamais simple provocation
en réalité pour joe biden bon c'est de
la provocation toute façon le y'aura pas
de test ça a été refusé
c'est pas comme les cyclistes à la fin
d'une étape du tour de france ça se
passera pas comme ça mais c'est un moyen
de rappeler que basly pidjot que joe
lando remis en effet
alors petits soucis de son gérard
lolivier
oui qu'il faut pour diriger le pays elle
vous laisse finir en reprendre cette
dernière réponse pour vous a pas entendu
sur la provocation c'est une simple
provocation et d'avoir répondu à nos
questions je rappelle que vous êtes
journaliste et chercheur a dit espérer
et auteur de sur la route de la maison
blanche aux éditions jean picollec